Russian President Vladimir Putin has
arrived in Uzbekistan where he's due to
meet with his Chinese counterpart as Xi
Jinping it'll take place on the
sidelines of a summit of the Shanghai
cooperation organization in the ancient
Silk Road City of samakand now the
summit will focus on Regional security
issues and is being touted as a
challenge to Western Global influence it
were the first meeting between the
Russian and Chinese leaders since Russia
invaded Ukraine
the last time Chinese president Xi
Jinping met Russian President Vladimir
Putin in Beijing he declared there were
no limits to the friendship between the
two superpowers
that was just days before Russia invaded
Ukraine
then Beijing has been largely silent
about the kremlin's war against its
neighbor other than saying that China
supports peace talks
Russia and China have also been making
their deepening partnership plain to see
for the rest of the World by conducting
joint military exercises on Land Air and
sea
China for its part can count on Russia's
staying out of what it sees as its
domestic affairs most importantly
tensions over Taiwan which Beijing
regards as a breakaway province
Beijing has been stepping up its
military activities around the island in
response to recent high-profile visits
to Taiwan by senior U.S lawmakers
China continues to play an important
indirect role in financing the kremlin's
War Machine by supporting Russia's
economy with increased energy Imports
while Russia has lost markets in the
west trade with China has soared by a
third this year
China has said presidents XI and Putin
are working together to shape what
Beijing calls a more just World Order
let's look at this with Andrew small
he's a China expert and a senior
transatlantic fellow with the Asia
program and the German martial fund of
the United States welcome to DW as we
mentioned this is president xi's first
trip outside that China since the
pandemic does that mean he regards this
Summit as particularly important
all the decisions about these trips are
always extremely symbolic he could have
made this a virtual Summit If he if he'd
wanted to
um instead it means he can do a kind of
comfort zone multilateralism almost
ahead of the party Congress it gives him
a chance to see some of China's closest
Partners especially Putin of course with
whom really these meetings have always
been a priority since the very beginning
of his time as party secretary and it
means he can put on this strong show of
a non-western gathering Counterpoint to
G7 to Nato at an organization the
Shanghai cooperation organization that's
of China's own creation I think she at
the moment wants to show that in this
struggle with the United States in the
struggle with the West that China has
friends too and then it can put on a
kind of visible show of that
all right I'm I'm going to have that
expression put on a mug I think comfort
zone multilateralism
um in February before the the Russian
invasion of Ukraine uh the two leaders
declared there were no limits to their
partnership China also as you said
hasn't condemned Russia's Invasion so
is beijing's support for Moscow
unconditional
well political support yes diplomatic
propaganda as we've seen and as you
mentioned in the segment some forms of
economic support too the natural
resource purchases but but also helping
Russia navigate some of the financial
constraints that the U.S sanctions have
imposed and I think there are other
areas there's forms of military support
that China will be wary or about
um even certain arms supplies uh this
isn't really material to the conflict
and the reforms of sanctioned support as
well where I think China certainly
doesn't want to impose costs on its own
companies where it's still quite
dependent on Western technology and the
Western Financial system but it's
certainly unconditional support in the
sense that it doesn't really matter what
Russia does China doesn't react to
stories of Russian atrocities or as you
mentioned in in the story attacks on
civilian infrastructure there's just
indifference to the actual conduct of
the war and I think they want to show
that they will continue to give
solidarity even if as we see at the
moment the Russian campaign is failing
so in that sense I think it that there
are significant the unconditional
elements to the forms of support that
China provides right and just talking
about this this this idea that the
Russian effort war effort is failing
they have the two countries have
conducted joint military exercises this
year is Russia's apparent failure in
Ukraine causing China perhaps to rethink
their military relationship
well I mean China had always been
with the Russian military operations
particularly in Crimea and in Syria and
they sort of hoped and expected that
Moscow would be able to pull off
something I think similar this time so
they were surprised that this was such a
failure they'll have been conducting
their assessments on on what went wrong
I think the sense had been that Russia
is good at the kind of lightning type
operations and less good at the longer
attritional ones like I think that will
certainly be be reinforced and but I
think the biggest concern on the Chinese
side with this will be what it might do
to Russia's Global capabilities that no
limits agreement in February that you
mentioned was was very much about the
two sides working together in third
regions in including militarily and
we've seen that to a certain extent even
in recent months in Asia but also the
Middle East in Africa I think the
concern China will have is whether
Russia's capabilities have been and
still are being worn down by this war
and therefore what level of cooperation
is likely to be able to sustain as a
result of that but I don't think it's a
trust question it's more concern about
and what this is going to do to to um
military that's very clear thank you so
much for outlining that to Forest Andrew
small from a German martial fund of the
United States
thank you
well DW's Moscow Bureau is now operating
from the Latvian Capital Riga and bureau
chief Yuri richardo joins us from there
welcome Yori what's expected to come out
of this meeting
well this meeting is important because
it will be the first time Phil both have
made such a major public appearance
outside the Zera countries since
February she hadn't even traveled abroad
since the pandemic started it is hard to
say exactly what the two will discuss
but of all the participants in
Uzbekistan probably only she and Turkish
president erdogan whom Putin is also
scheduled to meet can ask the Russian
president to end the war since the start
of the war China has stood firmly by
Russia's side China hasn't condemned
Russia's so-called special military
operation and China also hasn't joined
Western sanctions against Russia and
with Russia facing International
sanctions because of of the war in
Ukraine its relationship with China must
be increasingly important
absolutely China hasn't only been
important for Russia since February 24th
but already since 2014 when Russia
annexed Crimea already back then there
was suddenly a big rift in relations
between Moscow and to the west and that
was at the moment when Russia recognized
the importance of China for itself now
China is supposed to compensate
economically for everything that the
Russians are suddenly missing because of
the impact of Western sanctions
militarily there was an obvious closing
of ranks the other day during joint
military successes in Russia as far east
we saw the report the Chinese
participated in them this year and have
been a regular guest at Russian
wheelchair exercises for some time
already when it comes to foreign policy
it is extremely important for Putin to
show that he isn't isolated worldwide so
for this reason China is super important
for the Russians right and on that point
of isolation I I guess this this
conference the Shanghai cooperation
organization this is another opportunity
for the the Russian leaders to show that
he has International Friends
absolutely every appearance on
International stage is very important
for Putin as it shows that the Russian
president isn't isolated in this respect
this conference is also being generously
exploited for propaganda purposes in
Russia nevertheless Putin's trip to
Uzbekistan cannot improve the difficult
situation on the front in Ukraine and
consequently reduce the pressure that is
growing on Putin in his own country
thank you for that Yuri Yuri roschetta
in Riga